jetzt können Sie mal zum anderen Thema
äußern im eigenen was die Leute
mitgebracht das will ich sehr gerne
sagen ich möchte gerne über
Meinungsfreiheit reden man liest immer
wieder es geben in Deutschland keine
Meinungsfreiheit es gebe einen
rot-grünes meinungskartell man dürfen
gar nicht mehr seine Meinung sagen dass
er nicht ganz schrecklich das wird oft
geschrieben und mein Eindruck ist ein
ganz anderer wenn man Länder sucht keine
Meinungsfreiheit geht da muss man nach
Peking nach Moskau nach Teheran reisen
oder nach minskinder kann man sich bei
uns darf jeder sagen was er will in der
Tat hat man aber keinen Recht darauf
dass er nicht widersprochen wird wenn
man seine Meinung sagt und man muss sich
dem auch stellen wenn ich die Zeitung
lese habe ich jetzt von Rot Grün
überhaupt nicht den anderen wenn ich
spd-freundliche Meinung lesen will muss
ich fast den Vorrats lesen ist unsere
Parteizeitung ansonsten höre ich immer
nur ständig der Bundeskanzler seit
zögerlich was die Ukraine angeht und
verzagt die Bevölkerung die einen
anspricht sieht das ganz anders ein
Roman der sich ja auch mit diesem Haus
hier teilweise mit beschäftigt macht
deutlich dass da geworden wird für die
FDP es wird viel für schwarz grün
geworden das ist alles okay ich glaube
darüber nicht gehört zu denjenigen die
mit solchen Debatten immer Stellen
Meinungsfreiheit heißt auch dass man
bereit sein muss Argumente auszutauschen
daran mangelt es übrigens bei der
Kriegsfrage auch das ist dann gut dann
böse schwarz und weiß war und unwahr
statt dass man Argumente austauscht man
wird nicht für das kritisiert was man
sagt sondern für eine Karikatur davon
aber man muss sich dem stellen das ist
kein Ponyhof als Politiker muss man sich
im erst recht Stellen ich habe das immer
in meinem Leben getan und habe nicht den
Eindruck dass man darunter leidet ich
glaube nur manchmal haben keine guten
Argumente und deswegen ist diese
Weinerlichkeit gerade bei den
Konservativen dass er alles so
schrecklich rot grün also ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich habe das Buch noch
nicht gelesen ich werde das tun aber
wenn das sozusagen das Flaggschiff der
konservativen ist die dann dann in
Sprache und Inhalt so bescheiden
aber das Buch schon gelesen da geht's
gar nicht gut aber die Berichterstattung
sagen hat ja auch deutlich gemacht
das schaffe ich nur mit zwei Promille
was ich dann Zitaten gelesen habe was
das Problem in Deutschland
Studien für Sie mitgebracht aber eine
steht mir die fand ich ganz spannend und
zwar gehen wir mal nur zu den ARD
Volontären die Studie ist aus 2020 da
würden 92% grün rot rot wählen das ist
für ein öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
der übrigens von öffentlichen Geldern
bezahlt wird von GEZ Gebühr ist es
natürlich schon erschreckend für viele
Menschen in diesem Land wenn sie lesen
das 92% der ARD Volontäre grün rot rot
werden würden von der Studie von 2020
würden sie nicht sagen da gibt's
vielleicht doch ein klein wenig beim er
hin zu unserem ich weiß das nicht essen
was Leute wählen ist ja und wie solche
Umfragen sind schade und Rauch und was
Leute wählen sie sind Zeit soll geheim
ich weiß nicht ob sie eine Unfall schon
mal in Ihrem Hause gemacht haben wie
viele Leute da SPD wählen ich habe den
Eindruck dass ich da manchmal wenn ich
in Diskussion von bin relativ alleine
bin und man eins gegen drei argumentiert
ich nochmal ich glaube darüber nicht
dass ja
Produkte kaufen
das ist ja nun nicht so dass die
permanent die SPD gelobt wurde wenn ich
ARD den ZDF gucke ärgere ich mir genauso
auf die wenn ich andere Dinge lese und
sehe also ist das nicht mein Eindruck
ist nicht dass die Leute unterjocht
werden und schon gleich gar nicht dass
ich sie davon beeindrucken lassen also
wenn sich davon beeindrucken ließen wenn
das angeblich so wäre dann könnte ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass es Parteien
gibt die schon seit Jahren absolute Mehr
oder alleine regieren wie in Bayern sehr
kritischen Journalismus deswegen sie
sagen eigentlich heute hier ich bin
zufrieden mit der Presse in diesem Land
ich sag nur die Meinungsfreiheit können
in der Demokratie dazu man darf das nur
nicht damit verwechseln dass man Recht
bekommt und wenn ich keine guten
Argumente habe zum Beispiel dann muss
ich mich nicht beschweren und dann
gehört auch eine gewisse Leidenschaft
über uns dazu dass man das auch aushält
den dezent auszuhalten wissen Sie was
mich ärgert ich will das nicht verdienen
aber was mich ärgert wenn man hier
gibt's wenn wir genug reden Putin
Freunde oder Kriegstreiber Putin Freunde
das ist nicht rechtsradikalen und
vielleicht Frau Wagenknecht ich habe
damit nichts am Hut aber wenn man sich
erlauben differ der Meinung zu haben ist
man sofort da und da wünschte ich mir
ein bisschen mehr Bereitschaft zur
altmodische Dinge wie Argumente zu
verwenden stehen sie nicht die Frage
würde ich auch gerne an Herrn Kissler
geben es gibt ja genügend Studien die
zeigen dass die gefühlte
Meinungsfreiheit in diesem Land immer
immer schlechter wird also unter 50% der
Deutschen haben nach wie vor das Gefühl
noch ihre Meinung sagen zu können mich
persönlich alarmiert das es muss ja
Grund dafür geben dass es immer immer
wieder weniger Menschen gibt ihre
Meinung sagen und sind sie nicht
eigentlich in einer sehr privilegierten
Stellung weil als Politiker haben sich
das ja auch ausgesucht ich würde mich
übrigens auch niemals hinstellen und
sagen ich darf meine Meinung nicht sagen
ich sagte jeden Tag aber entschuldigen
sie mal darf ich immer sagen wenn die
Zeitung auch solche mit ganz großen
Buchstaben den Leuten ständig sein dass
man die Meinungsfreiheit bedroht dürfen
vielleicht ja zum Beispiel man könnte
den auch mal sagen da kommt man mit nach
Tiere an dann könnt ihr mal sehen wie
das Miteinander oder in unserem eigenen
Land vor 70 80 Jahren glaube heute zu
Tage passiert
Meinungsfreiheit der eine Punkte zweite
ist eben eine meinungsdominanz in den
Medien das sind zwei verschiedene Dinge
also wenn die Bild-Zeitung oder oder der
Spiegel immer zu irgendein bestimmte
Sache sagt dann ist das eine Geschichte
aber das ist ja dann damit ist die
Meinungsfreiheit ja nicht eingeschränkt
ich werde dir nicht gehauen wegen der
andere Meinung habe aber was sie eben
angesprochen haben die gefühlte es sind
ihm sehr viele Menschen die wahrnehmen
sie könnten dass sich das mag und ich
glaube auch das ist unsicht zutreffend
ist aber für die ist es real es ist eine
reale politische Einschränkung für diese
Menschen obwohl es vielleicht gar keinen
sachlichen Grund dafür gibt
ja ja das ist aber auch real,-
es gibt also ein Problem mit der
Meinungsfreiheit wie sie wahrgenommen
wird dass wir auf der anderen Seite ich
sehe das im klimageschäft was im
klimageschäft alles so erzählt wird was
schon vorkommen klar ist dass es mit dem
kipppunkten so und so jedermann weiß
dass sie um die Ecke sind wenn wir nicht
sofort diese jenes machen dass die
Berichterstattung über das Medium
dermaßen einseitig ist wenn ich mir mal
die ARD ansehe zum Beispiel dann wundert
mich schon warum werden kommen da
eigentlich immer die gleichen Leute zum
zum Worte und nicht mal eine
differenzierte oder vielleicht eine
andere Meinung aber das ist ein anderes
Thema das ist über die Dominanz in den
Medien der Spiegel ist leider vollkommen
umgefallen seitdem sie zusammengelegt
worden sind mit SPIEGEL ONLINE aber und
das andere ist die wahrgenommene
Meinungsfreiheit die war ja die gefühlte
dass sie wie ein wirklich kann alles
sein können und ich kann auch immer
alles sagen mir ist noch nie was
passiert da weil ich freche Sachen
gesagt habe das dem stimme ich ihn
Vorkommen zu aber es ist real das ist
Menschen gibt die Angst haben das zu
sagen was sie meinen wir gehen der
Schluss wird mal der weil die NZZ die
hat ja auf jeden Fall sagt sie ist
neutral
Schlusswort ich kann es relativ kurz
machen wir haben schon zwei Objektive
Probleme mit der Meinungsfreiheit a im
geisteswissenschaftlichen Bereich an
Universitäten wo bestimmte
Forschungsfelder gar nicht mehr für
forschungsattraktiv gehalten werden
keine Drittmittel mehr eingeworben
werden weil sie nicht dem Geist der
Zeiten entsprechen weil sie nicht der
Mainstreaming des Denkens entsprechend
vor einer Geisteswissenschaft es gibt
Initiative Geistesfreiheit können Sie
sich anschauen können viele Fälle
aufgelistet und zum anderen vergessen
leider die öffentlich rechtlichen Medien
an zu vielen Stellen dass sie vom Gesetz
das Recht haben von allen Menschen die
Deutschland leben Gebühren zu verlangen
dass sie aber nicht in der nötigen
breite die Meinungen aller gebührenzahl
aller Beitragszahl abdecken das ist ein
großes Problem wir haben oft talkshirt
und nicht alle aber oft talkshirten die
nicht Gleichgewichte besetzt sind in
denen nicht verschiedene Meinungen
aufeinanderprall Ukraine ist ein
Beispiel Corona war ein anderes Beispiel
und wir haben vor allen Dingen auch in
der kommen den Kommentaren
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien an vielen
Stellen eine weltansche schlagfertigen
können weil beispielsweise auch bei der
Studie die ich eben vorgetragen habe
über die Volontäre also für mich wäre es
auch furchtbar wenn jetzt der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk bei
Bewerbern immer fragt welche politische
Richtung haben Sie denn
das war ja eine einzige Unfallstelle
bei der Ukraine beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen was ist
da einseitig
schnacken ich sage Ukraine ist auch ein
Feld wo wir lange brauchen und
Meinungsfreiheit jetzt gestellt zu haben
aber auch lange nur ein ein narrativ
möglich also muss man sagen es war schon
lange Zeit ähnliche bei Corona eine
Überwachung
habe lange Zeit eine sehr einfach dann
habe ich verstanden
ich ganz einfach man muss einfach hat
eine Bringschuld
öffentliche abzudecken in ihrem Programm
die die konservativ sich ein selbst
einrichten und einsetzen oder vielleicht
sogar rechts und das Wort einmal zu
sagen die muss man auch abdecken mit
Position en vielleicht sogar auch mal
mit einem Format wo man auf einer
konservativen warte auf die Welt schaut
und nicht immer nur von linker Seite
also ich glaube die öffentlich
rechtlichen brauchen Mut so Vielfalt und
zwar Mut zur Meinungsvielfalt